you talked about how your uh
relationship with your daughter pippa
has changed your outlook on the world in
general
on on people in general i want i want to
get your take on how
the global dancing foundation um the
importance of the work that they are
doing
okay so the global down syndrome
foundation is incredible
and i am so grateful that they are here
one of the things that like blew my mind
when i was um
a new mom of uh someone with down
syndrome was
um the the lack of information that was
available
the lack of kind of medical information
that was available
um like my pediatrician didn't know a
lot about it and so like the the
the information that i was relying on
was really outdated
and um and the the things i'd heard
about down syndrome were outdated
and the global down syndrome foundation
um has a huge focus on like staying
current with research
a lot of the kind of medical
establishment
doesn't put the funding towards our
community in the way that
global does and so so michelle
and everybody there was able to really
give me information about like what
down syndrome actually is and how like
down syndrome's not the problem there
are some like co-morbidities that go
along with it
um and they have lots of information
about that like what is hypotonia
and what is what goes on with some of
the speech issues
um and so they were able to educate me
about that and talk about some of the
like health things that we're going to
need to look at and
where funding needs to be but they
really helped to dispel
fear about down syndrome and just get
into the business of doing research on
like okay
this is a difference what are some of
the things we need to be aware of
and how do we like maximize capacity in
life
and fulfillment and joy for everyone in
this community and so um they're they're
just doing such a great job
of really um mobilizing funds and
putting them in the right place
to both do medical research and research
about like how to make
everyone's life just happier and more
full
um living with down syndrome you know
one of the one of the bright lights that
we
lost recently was deandra dixon and i
wanted to
you know you know she and jamie both
were big advocates right obviously
they're advocating can you can you talk
about
the impact that they've had on even the
awareness
that the general public might have about
um
about down syndrome yeah i mean
we have had the amazing
privilege of having deandra dixon
in our lives for now over a decade so
she came to the first fashion show she
was the first quincy jones exceptional
advocacy award winner
quincy uh made the award in her honor
so she was the inspiration for so many
things
um so you know what we've lost of course
is her advocacy you know first of all
she's a female she's african-american
and she has down syndrome all those
things are actually important to global
right and um she was uh
really loving but she was also very a
matter of fact in her advocacy she knew
she
was born into a very loving family maybe
a privileged family
and she but she wanted to help others
she's like i understand other people
with down syndrome
are struggling how can i help them and
that was because
um her family was so wonderful
and how they brought her up just
treating her equal
and uh no different than any of the
other kids including jamie and deirdre
like they're all
equal and you can see how that empowered
her
and gave her confidence to stand up
and entertain she's a great entertainer
and taking that entertainment skill and
moving it into advocacy but i think
katarina you've met her too i mean is it
a
katarina would you what was your
impression of her and of course the
brother-sister relationship as well i
mean i
only got to meet deandre once which was
at the peanut butter falcon
premiere and she was amazing we kind of
spent the night hanging out and
um she was just a really chill hang she
was
really fun so um so i didn't know her
that well but
i i wish i had had more of an
opportunity to get to know her
and it is a huge loss for our whole
community um
she had a huge impact for everyone and
and i'm sure for her family
um yeah and the post the outpouring of
love i don't know if you've
looked at the um social media you know i
i would wager there's like maybe
300 people with down syndrome all you
know who are online
you know talking about this posting
things
and then their family members and then
people who were touched by deandra so
that the numbers get bigger and bigger
um you know i i just i can't imagine
what mr dixon and miss annette are going
through
you know um losing their their youngest
child
and no parent should have to go through
that and
i think we're very much committed to
doubling down
on research and medical care and making
sure we elongate life
and we improve health outcomes well
katerina you've been
taking some multiple platforms obviously
talking about this you know
you and pippa shared the cover of people
magazine which is a beautiful thing it
must have been such a fun shoot
but what do you you know when you um
when you share your story of what
living with her is like and what what
loving with her is like what do you hope
that people learn what does it
what do you want them to get from it um
i mean i think that
it's such a it's not just one
thing i think that
for me and i guess what i'm trying to
like transmit to people
is that entering the world of disability
uh
kind of completely collapsed the
assumptions and paradigms that i was
operating under
um and gave me an opportunity to kind of
redefine my relationship
uh with the entire world like all of the
people i knew
and with myself and and realizing how
much i'd kind of bought into
this idea that there were you know ways
that of being that were like
kind of better or ways of being that
were not as good and that was
totally wrong and it was so limiting to
my life and so
being given the gift of such a radical
perspective shift as becoming the mother
of someone who's very different
uh not that different it's a little bit
different
i i i almost i just want it's almost
like
i mean i think the tendency is to think
that like oh i'm doing this like great
thing
by being an advocate but really i feel
like i'm inviting people
into this amazing world that they've
been missing out
on of of seeing themselves and
everyone they love as beautiful in their
differentness
and just with needs with with equity
needs um
as opposed to like something that we
need to like be worried about or try to
avoid like don't
don't avoid life like yeah dance
come on make sure it's funded speaking
of graves as
the current global climate the with the
health crisis
everything that's going on has that
affected story lines or the way that
production has worked
what yeah what's happening for the new
season it's totally different this year
um we're all well we're doing a covid
storyline krista
vernov and shonda rhimes are a genius
and so they just worked it in
and so we're on set but everybody's
wearing ppe
so we've got like masks and visors and
like
uh pepper um it's like a breathing
device
um and and and then behind the scenes we
also have like people with sanitizer
everywhere and we're getting cover
tested
three times a week and we have zones so
i'm in the red zone and then there's a
yellow zone and
um and so we're and all of our chairs
now are like six feet apart in like
little circles with like plastic
so we're taking a lot of precautions um
but but i do feel like um
as everyone's so isolated i think um
in some ways entertainment is something
that's keeping us all
our morale high and so we've kind of
been saying we're essential workers
we're
we're like we we want to be there to
like provide
story and companionship and
accompaniment for all of these people
who are
heroically quarantining